well good evening from London and
welcome to a special edition of Piers
Morgan on Center Dr Jordan Peterson one
on one
he's a clinical psychologist turned
culture Warrior at one of the world's
most famous and Infamous intellectuals
his books are instant best sellers tens
of millions watch him online Legions of
fans swear by his straight talking
guidance what I've recommended to people
is clean up your room but his outspoken
views on issues like feminism The Taming
of the wild man essentially by the by
the desirable and virginal woman and if
you think women don't want that then you
better bloody well come up with an
explanation for Fifty Shades of Gray
agenda you won't use my pronouns so I'm
pretty sure you're my enemy yes yeah
well I know you think that but I don't
believe that using your pronouns is
going to do you any good in the long run
I've made him a lightning rod for
controversy almost 40 million people
have now seen this notorious interview
with a British news show you're
exercising your freedom of speech to
certainly risk offending me and that's
fine I think more power to you as far as
I'm concerned except you haven't sat
there and
I'm just trying I've just tried to work
that out I mean
ha gotcha celebrity friends face
criticism just for meeting him he's
loved he's loathed but he's never
ignored and tonight Jordan Peterson is
uncensored
well Jordan Peterson joins me now Jordan
Peterson welcome thank you to Piers
Morgan uncensored my first question and
there will be people genuinely wanting a
simple answer yeah but there's a bigger
answer too who is Jordan Peterson well
I'm a clinical psychologist and a
professor and I'm doing that on a
broader scale now I suppose and but it's
an extension of what I've done since
1987 really I mean I I taught the same
things I'm teaching although I've
expanded them
all throughout my academic career and my
classes were very popular and and not
popular exactly
they the students found them extremely
useful should should any lectures any
University ever be popular should they
always be challenging it's one of the
problems we have in modern society that
students aren't challenged enough
well they were challenging they were
plenty challenging I mean the students
the students had two comments usually
they said it's very difficult for me to
talk to anyone else about what I'm
learning in this class because it's so
different and also that it changed the
way I looked at everything so they were
there's no shortage of challenge yeah I
mean
everyone wants an optimal challenge you
know that's that's in the nature of play
to have an optimal challenge why have
you become so notorious because I I look
at it as I've actually watched a lot of
your lectures I've listened to hours of
you and Joe Rogan talking about stuff I
don't see the devil that some people try
and portray you as at all and it seems
to me the one thing we may share in
common is certainly not intellectual
prowess where unfortunately I've many
yards behind you but what we do show I
think is a lot of people seem to drawn
an opinion about us based on either what
they've seen in a tiny clip taken out of
context a lot of the time or what
they've been told to Think About You by
other people yeah well that's some of it
I mean I got tangled up in a political
controversy in Canada I mean tangled up
I put my foot in it to some degree
because I wasn't very happy with what I
regarded as Government overreach in
relationship to who is in possession of
my tongue and and I decided a long time
ago and really a long time ago that I
was going to say what I thought and sort
of independent of the outcome you know
often people craft their speech you know
I could come here on your show for
example I spent half an hour thinking
well what do I want out of this show but
I don't think like that I wanted to come
here and have a conversation with you
actually make notes on top before you're
big I make notes but I generally don't
use them so I have to prepare you know
another are they different when you go
on tour is every night different yes I
never do this how do you decide what to
talk about well at the moment sometimes
I'm taking questions from the audience
and so I just do a q a but I don't look
at the questions before I go on stage
and I ask my wife who asked me the
questions not to show them to me and
then if I prepare a lecture I usually
have a question in mind often that
relates to one of the topics in my books
but all but sometimes something I'm
thinking about and then I use the
lecture as an opportunity to explore
that question and answer it well I'm
watching the audience to see if my words
are landing and so it's an opportunity
to think on my feet and I think part of
the reason the lectures are
are well attended is because it's a high
wire act in some sense because I never
know when I go on stage whether I'm
going to bring the lecture to something
like a punch line to something like a
conclusion so and I have no idea because
I'll have a variety of ideas up in the
air nothing extraordinary you have no
idea where it may lead to no
no no it's an exercise it's a little
scary I mean
yes
but you know there's an idea that the
truth will set you free right and and
that's a very strange idea because you
could imagine that I could come here and
I could decide there are things I want
to do to promote my books let's say and
I could tilt our conversation towards
that or I could just say well I'm going
to pay attention to what's going on here
and I'm going to see what happens and
I'm going to say what I think and then
I'm going to assume that whatever the
outcome is is the right outcome because
it was based on something approximating
the truth what is your ultimately what
is your goal what is what is the point
of Dr Jordan Peterson what do you hope
to achieve through what is now huge
Global Fame
um I hope to encourage people other than
that I want to see what happens you know
I want to say what I believe to be true
as clearly and
and carefully as I possibly can and I
want to see what happens as a
consequence and what people don't
understand about that in some sense is
your happiness the purpose of your life
is not going to be happiness sometimes
it is
sometimes that will come but there will
be difficult periods in your life and
happiness won't suffice that but what
you can have in your life is an
adventure you can have an adventure and
the truth is the best adventure there's
no doubt about that and there's a couple
of reasons for that one is you don't
know what's going to happen if you say
what you think now I don't mean in
cautiously and I don't mean
provocatively or any more than necessary
you don't know what's going to happen so
that's very adventurous but also if it's
you and your voice then it's your
adventure and if it isn't like if you're
crafting your speech or manipulating in
any way or parroting or abiding by the
dictates of the crowd
then I don't know whose Adventure you're
having but it's not yours see I'm I'm on
the show Piers Morgan uncensored because
ironically I got censored I was doing a
morning show another Network and after
the Meghan Markle Prince Harry interview
on Oprah Winfrey I said I didn't believe
a word that she was saying Meghan Markle
and I was told I had to apologize oh yes
and I said well why would I apologize
for an honestly held opinion there is a
question I didn't believe it but I'll
tell you either you apologize or you
lose your job yeah so I took me losing
the job option rather than compromise my
free speech ideas was that a good idea
yes I think so well because ultimately I
think you've got to be true to yourself
well whether you're true to something
else well I I think we're in a weird
world actually driven by people like
Meghan Markle where she talks about my
truth yeah I don't understand what my
truth means it means do what I want
right but my truth doesn't actually
exist there is the truth which is
fact-based yeah and unarguable and then
there is opinion around fact and truth
you can't have your own version of the
truth it seems well you have it's
complicated because when people say that
they they are referring to to the degree
that they're referring to anything that
there are some experiences that are in
some ways purely subjective and they're
also valid in their subject activity so
for example if you're sitting there and
you say I'm in pain and it's assuming I
believe you're not manipulating me I
don't have access to that pain but I'm
it's reasonable for me to assume that
the that's a genuine experience on your
part and act accordingly and so there is
a realm where experience is valid that's
subjective but that doesn't mean that
everything that happens to you
subjectively is now to be regarded by
Fiat as the truth I have to abide
shouldn't we in a democracy should it
not be my right to listen to you with
great respect and then say I don't
believe a word of what you've just said
it's also your responsibility it's not
just your right and it's also one of the
things people don't understand is that
that ability of the other person to
oppose or reign in or satirize or dance
with or joke or play with all of those
things they're also what keeps you
together insane because we all have a
tendency to drift in our weakest Place
let's say and so some people become
alcoholic and some people will become
narcissistic and so on we all have our
Temptations and one of the ways we
buttress ourselves against that is by
having other people say no you there
you're not funny there you're boring
they're you need to be reigned in and if
you deprive yourself of that that's what
happens to hyper celebrities and
dictators they deprive themselves of
that social regulation because they
forbid it and then they're then they're
in hell and sometimes they drag everyone
along with them too so yeah really on
Free Speech
it seems to me in my 57 years of being
on this planet the Free Speech has never
been under more ferocious attack not in
places you would expect like
authoritarian regimes but actually in in
democracies I never thought I'd come to
a day in my lifetime where people were
literally being fired or in some cases
imprisoned for expressing honestly held
opinions even if I find those opinions
grotesquely wrong or offensive you know
it's worse than that people
underestimate the significance of this
because it isn't we're not having a
fight about who has the right to speak
freely that's nothing that's that's
that's a peripheral problem even though
that can be serious in and of itself
we're having a fight about whether or
not your claim
that Free Speech exists is nothing but a
masquerade for your willingness to
dominate and use power and so if I was
taking that attack I'd say it's all well
and good for you to speak about Free
Speech but look you're white and your
middle class and you're British and
you're and you're privileged and you
have this theory about free speech that
your ancestors drive but the only reason
they ever derive that to begin with is
so they could exercise their power
there's no such thing as free speech
that's just a lie to mask a power claim
and that's a way worse
cynical criticism of the notion of free
speech then you can't speak because I
don't agree with I mean it's a form of
fascism isn't it I mean these people
it's worse than that the kind of the
ultra woke uh Brigade out there they
they categorize themselves as liberals
but there's nothing liberal about that
mentality when you have a canceled
culture which is driven by if you don't
agree with what I say you're going to
get shame vilified canceled fired maybe
even in prison that is actually what
fascist regimes do to people to their
possible yeah but the fascists are more
straightforward about it because they
basically come out and say something
like shut up or we'll beat you right
whereas the compassionate types
who are narcissistic compassionate
compassionate types they come out and
say well we're really trying to save the
world you know and we're we're acting in
everyone's best interests and we think
it would be better if if you should just
you know regulate what you say because
if you don't you're not you're not a
good person
and so that's it's much more I'd take
the fascist bully over the narcissistic
over the compassionate narcissist any
time they're way more straightforward I
mean we live again in an era where the
hashtag be kind yeah yeah almost
invariably is used by people who are the
least kind people I think I've ever
encountered in other words people that
love to be utterly vicious yeah well
kind of yeah they hide behind this fake
persona of hashtag be kind yeah yeah
well kindness is tricky you know because
one of the things you deal with very
commonly if you're a clinical
psychologist apart from depression and
anxiety is well Behavior therapists
offer assertiveness training and now the
people who need assertiveness training
are often people who are too agreeable
compassionate polite by temperament now
the problem with that is that they let
every other they let people walk all
over them because they don't they don't
stand up enough for themselves and the
consequence of that is they get resent
full and then they get bitter and then
they get conniving and then they get and
then they'll mob and so because they're
not
they'll do anything for everyone else
but
they push themselves beyond their limits
and they and then they won't even
recognize the limits because they feel
well if I'm not doing everything for you
then then I'm not a good person it's
like no a good person does a little for
you like if I'm acting properly with you
say in this conversation there's
something in it for you and there's
something in it for me right and we want
that to be reciprocal and so the cost of
me bending too far in your direction is
that I'll become bitter and resentful
and conniving and and that and
resentment is non-believably toxic state
of being it's like a short break I want
to come back and talk to you about what
a random collection of people Cristiano
Ronaldo the most famous footballer on
the planet the greatest in my opinion
also a head teacher Catherine bubble
Singh where you went to her school and
all hell broke loose and also Olivia
Wilde who's made a movie in which she
said it's about you because you're the
guy that drives some of the worst human
beings on planet Earth you want to talk
about all those things off the bromine
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensor said one on one
with Dr Jordan Peterson so a weird thing
happened uh about two weeks ago I was on
Instagram I suddenly unpopped this
picture
and it was you with a friend of mine
Cristiano Ronaldo the the Football
Genius greatest player to ever play the
game as far as I'm concerned and you'd
need to see it uh just privately
and he was saying how great it was that
he'd met you and you'd gone there and
all hell broke this he was bombarded
with people saying this is outrageous
Legend over Legacy finished none of
which would have bothered him because
he's heard all this kind of thing before
but the Venom of it was from certain
quarters was so pathetic it seemed to me
so first of all
what were you doing with Cristiano why
why were you there well he invited me to
come and see him and um he had had some
trouble in his life a few months ago and
a friend of his sent him some of my
videos and he said he had watched those
and then he read my book one of my books
and found them very helpful and he
wanted to talk so I went out to his
house and we talked for about two hours
and he showed me all his equipment for
keeping himself in Tip-Top condition and
we talked a bit about his companies and
but mostly we talked about what he
wanted in the future and some of the
obstacles that he's facing while
pursuing that and so we had a strategic
conversation I would say for for about
on those topics for about 90 minutes
were you in a way were you that the Ted
lasso figure in his life well that's
what it felt he didn't realize he was
missing yeah well I think maybe he did
realize that he was missing it because
he seemed to have found it to some
degree in those lectures and so and I
was I I always like to hear not only
what people are up to but what they want
and I one of the things I loved about my
clinical practice which was very much
predicated on this like well you're
miserable let's say and not to say that
he was because he has a good life in
many ways but
if you could Envision a path forward out
of your misery let's say to somewhere
better what would that look like and
it's not a question people ask
themselves with enough depth and then
having developed that vision
what are the strategies that might be
put in place to make that more likely
and again not in a manipulative way but
if you had to conduct yourself in the
proper manner to bring about this
desirable end or at least to move
towards it how would you how would you
organize your behavior when someone like
Cristiano who you know we know what the
personal problem was he'd lost a baby
and his partner was incredibly sad for
him and professionally after that a lot
of turmoil as to whether he was going to
stay at his club and so on and so on
um it seemed to me talking to him in the
last couple of days after he saw you
he's in a much better place actually
that's what happens when you hang out
with reprobate like yes but really
interesting to me that so you got and
you and he both got criticized for just
seeing each other
um but actually it was clearly very
helpful too well I hope so that would be
lovely if it was true
it's a weird position isn't it there's
you Dr Jordan Peterson this guy that
comes out of Canada lecturing students
and then you're at the home of the
greatest football player of all time and
you're genuinely helping him I mean
Ronaldo is known as one of those
mentally strong athletes has ever been
yeah right not just physically but
mentally strong and yet he needed
someone like you to help him I find that
really fascinating well I don't know if
he needed me because he's a pretty
competent guy but but you know you can
always and this is something that very
competent people do you can always
improve on edge you know and so his life
is very well put together and he had
some trouble but people do but we talked
a lot about what he wanted how he wanted
his career to end in in the most
graceful possible Manner and how that
might be optimized and so I hope you
told him very well to sign for Arsenal
in the January transfer window did you
Jordan no I didn't give him I don't give
I try not to give people advice I mean
I'm curious on that because he's
obviously reaching not not the end of
his career by any means he's still the
world-class player and he's incredibly
fit so he could play for another three
four years perhaps but what is an end
game for someone who's achieved
everything in the game yeah well it
that's a good question it's hard for
people who who have had a stellar career
especially one that's to some degree
predicated on youth to figure out what
to do with the rest of their life now
he's well set up because he's a very
canny businessman and he has a young
family and he has lots of friends and as
far as I could tell on that front he's
situated himself extremely intelligently
so I think it looks to me like the
transition for him is going to be quite
smooth so but that's a testament to his
wisdom because he made sure that his
life was
was was founded on more than one
dimension of of attainment and that was
very wise
does it make you feel good that even
people like him can find great Solace
from watching your lectures
well all that makes me feel good I mean
I do think that this is part of the
reason I keep going on these lecture
tours is that it seems to be doing
people good so
despite that and despite a lot of people
testifying you do do good for them you
went to a school really interesting
School the Michaela Community School in
North London run by this fascinating
head teacher Catherine berbil Singh who
runs a pretty tough school but has
amazing results at this school and as a
result of you going she got bombarded
without from people and she took it on
head on actually and went yeah I'm sorry
we're going to keep inviting people with
all different views all different types
of people and that's going to include
people like Jordan Peterson she owned it
and she was proud that you went to her
school tell me about that visit what do
you think of her as well well people
think of her school as tough and that
she's this Dragon Lady and that isn't
what I saw what I saw was that she was
playing a very sophisticated game with
her students and games have rules
and if you don't enforce the rules then
the game doesn't play properly and every
game has a referee because someone has
to enforce the rules and she's a very
very sophisticated referee and she's
playing an unbelievably sophisticated
game and the students are so alert and
on target their attention is so well
regulated by themselves like for example
when we walked into her classrooms we
walked into about seven we were LED
around by three relatively small kids
who were very articulate and together
and attentive and polite and focused
when we walked into her classes the
students didn't
turn their eyes away from their teacher
to look at us there was no buzz of
conversation they were just focused on
their teacher and their teacher was
focused too it's like we could walk in
and the whole thing just continued
around us and that was really something
to see and fast-paced man the teachers
were spitting out information as fast as
I've ever heard anyone spit out
information and the students were
reacting like just like just like it was
choreographed and the truth is it works
I mean recently this school well that's
annoying yeah right I mean it's annoying
for those who immediately howl this is
disgusting these poor kids oh yeah those
poor kids 80 of the students achieve
four plus C or more in their GCSE is a
very good results despite being
non-selective right that's a big deal a
huge deal
and yet she gets castigated for it which
says to me that my sort of gut feeling
that we've just gone a bit soft enough
it's annoying when you help out the
victims because then there's no one to
be like narcissistically compassionate
about them so and that's certainly the
situation she's in yeah it's quite
amazing that she's managed this with
with kids who are a non-selected sample
and I asked her you know well how many
kids do you have to expel let's say for
serious misbehavior and she said it's
only been a tiny handful and I said well
how many kids can't adjust to the more
rigorous pace and she said well they
they can all adjust and that's what I
saw I mean I never saw I never saw a
bunch of children a group of children
that were more focused and alert than I
saw at that school and it was really
hard trending in some sense Yeah by you
going there they people actually
reported her to the police for a hate
crime yeah just by your presence in that
school that's the problem with hate
crime legislations like who defines hate
and I know the answer to that who
defines hate the people you lease want
to
so you know you want hate crime
legislation you just better keep in mind
who's going to Define what constitutes
hate and then you think about the people
you're enabling these rat Finks these
people who didn't learn not to
tattletail on their peers when they were
children who run to totalitarian
authority to wield their resentful power
now that's all part of the legal code
it's like well we'll see where that goes
well we know where it goes It goes so
that you know
demented half-wit resentful narcissists
can rat out Kate herbal sing to the
police yes yeah well that's not good not
at all and who knows where it'll end up
it's it's terrifying actually that that
should happen in a Democratic Society
let me ask you about
um
kids
What You by kids I mean young adults
really and then into their their 20s
trying to form their way through life
one of my favorite movie clips is Rocky
Balboa it's probably the
non-intellectual version of Jordan
Peterson in many ways because he said
this to his son he was getting a bit
spoiled and entitled and moaning about
being Rocky Summers on and he says this
to him
I love that speech yeah it's good what
do you think of it well that ethos was
what lifted up
Sylvester Stallone to start him very
rapidly with his first movie and what do
I think about that I think that young
people are literally dying for that
message I really and I mean literally
they're so demoralized it's just beyond
belief and so one of the things that's
been painful about what I've been doing
with my wife as we've traveled around
the world for the last number of years
is to see how desperate people are for
an encouraging word
let's take a break and find out what
that encouraging word should be I want
to know why a lot of young people are
very anxious about life why is that and
what's the best way for them to come
through it yeah well welcome back to the
special edition of Facebook organization
one-on-one with Dr Jordan Peterson we
left them on the Cliffhanger with Rocky
Balboa and his address to his son about
how to grow a pair for one of a better
phrase
um this idea that actually your life is
defined not So Much by success because
you're everyone's friend when you're
successful but by The Knocks you
inevitably are going to get whether it's
through losing loved ones losing a job
you know losing a car whatever it may be
you're going to get hit by blows in your
life of differing magnitude and I've
always believed that how you deal with
the the downside of life really defines
how you lead the rest of your life well
the clip is very interesting because it
starts out with the admission that life
is brutally difficult and sometimes
unbearably brutally difficult and and
you can see the progressives playing
with that notion it's it's it it's
warped into this sense of victimization
but it does does reflect some
understanding of the underlying tragic
reality of life and so it's good to get
that radar on the table to begin with
say well you're miserable you have your
reasons and they might be deep reasons
but
if you let the misery demoralize you and
make you bitter and cynical and cowardly
and make you withdraw then
first of all that's a failure in that
highest Sense on your part and all it's
going to do is make everything worse and
then you might think well what do you
have
to to to respond to that how do you
respond to that
catastrophe and Challenge and the answer
is and this is what Rocky is telling his
son in no uncertain terms it's like
terrible as things are there's a lot
more to you than you can possibly
imagine and that if you face those
things forthrightly and with some faith
and courage then you can you can you can
have the adventure of your life and
Prevail even over catastrophe and that's
true right I mean I I couldn't really
get my head around why so many young
people feel so anxious all the time
compared to when I was young when it
just that wasn't really a big thing
amongst my friendship groups certainly
but I I reckon there's two things one
social media uh the constant bombardment
of other people having a great time or
looking great often of course imagery
and like having to live up to full-size
deals but also the conversation I have
with Dr Phil in America where his
explanation for it was that he said
you've got to understand that social
media means that young people now are
being bombarded all day long and all
night long with quite shocking imagery
and he gave an example he said when I
was young he said if a crocodile ate
somebody on a golf course in Florida the
chances are I would never have heard
about it it probably wouldn't have made
the national news probably wouldn't have
even made the state news and I wouldn't
have heard about this incident now it's
quite likely that a video of the
crocodile eating this person would be
whipping its way around social media
within half an hour and young kids will
be sharing it disseminating it and being
exposed to this constant imagery all the
time of quite unsettling and shocking
imagery what do you think of that theory
and that well I think that in itself was
adding to a sense of everything's
terrible well I think it's a corollary
of an information overload Theory right
I mean one of the advantages to having
to having the computational power we
have is that everything is at your
fingertips and the disadvantages that
everything's in your face and by
everything it might be 40 million
pornographic images like that's a lot or
an endless array of tragic scenarios and
really endless and so that's a problem
and the problem the fundamental problems
how do you handle the fire hose of
information and no one really knows the
answer to that but we should also point
out that it's no wonder that young
people are demoralized and anxious
because we're doing everything we can to
demoralize them and make them anxious so
on the masculine front we we tell young
boys that while the world's a terrible
patriarchal tyranny and all of that
patriarchal tyranny which is the whole
explanation for history has done nothing
but it'll pay press and exploit people
and destroy the planet and so that any
manifestation of that masculine impulse
on your part is equivalent to the world
destroying Force when all masculinity
now is branded toxic yeah and I remember
I think that the key moment from
becoming Gillette who'd always had these
very masculine commercials with the big
guy cuddling a baby or whatever it may
be they suddenly switch gears and did a
campaign where it started with a lot of
metoo imagery and basically the
assumption that all men are awful until
they can prove otherwise and I predicted
in a column this would be a complete
disaster for them and sure enough nine
billion dollars later they did a
screeching U-turn and went back to the
big guy cuddling the babies because
actually two things I think about that
one most men are not awful actually and
so not all the time some better
obviously um some women are pretty awful
no but not most of them but if you try
saying that and not getting canceled um
but I think also this thing that you've
got into trouble about which I don't
understand why that you believe that
most women
probably quite like their men to be
strong and confident I don't believe
that all the data shows right clearly I
like cultural samples and has for 50
years plus everywhere anecdotally most
women I know I think would absolutely
agree why is it that you've been so
vilified for suggesting something which
is so palpably true well I think first
of all that annoys narcissistic women no
end and it annoys people who thinks that
think that there are no biological or
cultural limits on how we manifest our
behaviors and also it it frightens a
large number of women because many women
have never had a good relationship with
anyone masculine in their life and so
the notion that they would need to
establish a trusting relationship with a
man especially if he's also in something
approximating a superordinate position
which is much what they might like to
find him maximally attractive also
implies that they're in some sense going
to be under his Sway and if there's no
trust there well that's absolutely
terrible fine and I have some sympathy
for that because there are no shortage
of women out there who've never had a
positive relationship with anyone
masculine and so they're very they're
completely unable to discriminate
between
narcissistic power and compulsion and
confident competence and so because they
can't distinguish that and they're
afraid they put all of that in the same
category which is something like the
Predator category and and that's not
good for them because well as you said
all men aren't Predators all the time
and they need to establish a
relationship with a man right we're also
in a very strange place where a lot of
high-profile women
will not say what they think a woman is
yeah because they are potentially Brian
Jackson the new member of the Supreme
Court in her nomination hearings was
asked a question this is what she said
as you say a Hot Topic today it could
certainly be litigated
um so I'm not in a position to to say
more about
whether or not
um it's actually one of the unenumerated
it was a riveting moment because you're
like you're going to be on the Supreme
Court of the United States of America
you're a woman you're the first black
woman on the court and that in itself I
know you've raised eyebrows about why
did Joe Biden go out there and say we
need to have a black woman why not to
say we want the best person available
and then if she's the best person get
her on the court which I completely
agree with but for her not to be able to
commit to explaining what she thinks a
woman is and then I had a moment on this
show where Macy Gray the singer did
stick her neck out and she said this
I will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman just because you
go change your plots doesn't make you a
woman right sorry
you feel that I know that for a fact
like if you want me to call you her I
will because that's what you want but
that doesn't make you a woman just
because I call you or her and just
because you got a surgery
with chilling predictability Macy Gray
stuck to her guns for a couple of days
and then the onslaught was so
overwhelming against us she had to go on
National Television in America issue a
groveling apology for everyone that
she'd hurt with this statement of what
many would think is just a statement of
biological fact
how we got to this place where women are
terrified of saying what a woman is and
women who do say what they think it is
I.E they're a clear biological
distinctions between a man and a woman
they get destroyed well we've accepted
this Preposterous hypothesis that your
identity is only subjectively defined
and as I've tried to point out on some
of my like in some of my lectures
the only people who think their identity
is subjectively defined are
two-year-olds and I mean that
technically because two-year-olds are
egocentric which means they can't bring
their identity in alignment with a
social Norm which also means that
two-year-olds can't play with other
children they can play beside them but
they can't play with them that doesn't
happen until you're three what happens
when you're three if you're reasonably
well socialized or start to move towards
that is that you learn how to negotiate
a social identity and then identity
becomes obviously it has a root some
roots in your subjectivity and in your
biology for that matter but a
sophisticated identity is not only
socially negotiated as the
constructivists know perfectly well but
it's also it's got a dynamism about it
because it has to be constantly
renegotiated like as we're having a
conversation here to some degree we're
renegotiating our mutual identities
because we learn something from each
other right so we transform right we're
also trying to figure out to some degree
who each of of us is in this situation
and then we're also trying to learn can
we play together towards some productive
end and you might ask well what do you
mean play and say well we're trying to
have an interesting conversation that's
a form of play and if you won't
negotiate and I won't negotiate how in
the world are we going to have a
conversation well this is the whole
problem with the transgender debate
particularly in things like sport is
there's simply no willingness on the
part of the transgender part of this
debate to have any conversation about
potential unfortunately created by
what's happening and I say you've got to
have the conversation yeah but we we
talked about that earlier the people who
really push this or the ideas that
govern this was a better way of thinking
about it there is no this is a very
difficult thing to understand you think
there's such a thing as reasonable
conversation
that's not on the table for the radicals
no it's not see reason the I the your
notion of reasonable conversation is
nothing but your insistence that your
ethos is dominates and their response is
always well then you're transphobic yeah
well uh or you're racist or your body or
your biological essentialist or
something whatever it is yeah um let's
take another break I want to come back
and talk to you about the royal family
in this country and the huge seismic
moment in history we've just had and
also the war in Ukraine Vladimir Putin
you're big on personalities I don't know
what you think about him what's up two
children start to break again welcome
back for my final part with Dr Jordan
Peterson the royal family uh and the
death of this great queen and the
extraordinary outpouring of love and
respect not just here but around the
world actually biggest event of his kind
I think I've ever seen what did you make
of it what do you think of a monarchy in
the modern Asia is it survivable
well I thought that what happened was
extremely interesting psychologically
because Queen Elizabeth stood for or
embodied a whole set of Virtues which is
the right way of thinking about it that
aren't in the least bit fashionable but
in fact they're the inverse of
fashionable in some sense but are
desperately needed and so you might say
humility uh dutifulness uh careful
emotional self-regulation
discretion uh the antithesis of
narcissism all of that and she managed
it extraordinarily well for 70 years and
so whenever things go too far in One
Direction there's a tremendous
unconscious or implicit desire for
something that would set it right and
that's what you saw happen and not only
on on the personal front but there's
also all the Pomp and ceremony which is
also archaic and and unfashionable that
was all part of that that you Brits
managed so spectacularly that was all
people are just dying for that for that
for that beauty what I felt was I felt
like the country before this happened
two weeks before it felt like the whole
country was in a shambolic state that
everything was going wrong in our
country and in a way the death of the
queen unified us in a way we hadn't been
for a long time yeah certainly since
brexit
um no one was talking about hot button
political issues or social issues
they're all talking about one thing and
that it also reinforced our national
identity oh yeah in a way they actually
made the world look on with great awe
about the procession our military our
royal family the country it made people
feel good about Britain again yeah and
therefore made British people feel good
about themselves again yeah well you
guys have lots to feel good about and
that's not the standard Mantra of the
modern world you know this is an
unbelievably admirable country for all
its flaws and so what do you find
vulnerable about us
English common law
the the the tradition of free speech uh
sardonic and self-effacing humor that's
so much a part of the culture
the our ability to queue for 13 hours
yeah politely to see a woman lying a
state is not even a member of our family
resilience well and to do that
peacefully and to do that in the spirit
of mutual Good Will and come to a place
like London it's unbelievably ethnically
diverse and yet it functions
extraordinarily well and you're the
birthplace of the I would say the
greatest democracies on Earth and that's
not accidental I mean the reason that
places like Canada New Zealand and
Australia and the United States flourish
is because their whole culture is
grounded in the English tradition and
the English common law tradition and uh
you can say what you want about those
countries but there are worse places to
live
so and you know you say that we have a
lot of good traits and bad traits and I
completely agree and the good I think
outweighs the bad if you look at
yourself the same analysis what are your
best traits and what are the the worst
traits of Dr Jordan Peterson
well I think that it's been difficult
for me to to optimally regulate my
irritation at times over the last few
years
um and I'm trying to get that right to
figure out what the right because a lot
of things that have happened have
outraged me and then I'm not exactly
sure what emotional tone to take as a
consequence of that outrage and that's a
very complicated thing to figure out and
that's been exacerbated that problem by
the fact that I have been my family and
I have been the targets of very
conniving
um and and attacks and underground
attacks and that isn't stopping I mean
another time when your wife was fighting
a deadly cancer yeah
so was I so yeah yeah so it's very
difficult to regulate your your temper
properly under those circumstances let's
say and so I don't imagine where have
you most improved yourself do you think
as you got older
I get better and better at listening you
know and I'm better and better at
finding my way forward with the words
that I choose and that's just it's just
a continual in some sense incremental
expansion I probably got better too at
seeking out corrective information so
for example I got banned from Twitter
recently for making a statement that I
don't regret by the way but I had a
friend of mine two friends of mine Grill
me and I put that on YouTube that's
called Mean Tweets the it was an hour
and a half I said and one of them both
of them are very very smart people one
of them is more liberal than I am I
would say and but a very good advocate
for that liberal position and I I said
well let's hash this out there's some
things I've said that have made people
angry and you think I made them
unnecessarily angry and that I was
unnecessarily harsh in my tone did they
change their mind
they changed my Approach
you know because one of the things I
decided was that I would try to be
equally
judicious in my words but that I would
use a a calmer and more measured tone
and I don't mean use instrumentally I
mean that I would attempt to make the
effort to take as much unnecessary
emotion out of the
statement as possible and so I started
to do that in some of my more recent
videos I mean I tried to do that before
I think part of the reason that my
interview with Kathy Newman went well
was because I kept my head and I didn't
get irritated I had she's a good friend
of mine and I watched it with great
interest because I felt like you were
slightly on parallel lines and that
maybe she would do that interview
differently if she had her time again I
think that's highly possible yeah so so
yes I changed my Approach quite
dramatically and what happened was that
I I read a telegraph article I recently
published about Deloitte and it was a
very cutting article and I was really
worried about publishing it because I
think it was the most cutting article
I've ever written and I read it on
YouTube very very calmly and carefully
and what happened was
I got
the response was much more positive and
much less negative so there was no
downside to it so people didn't say some
people said I you know I think that I
like your tone when you were more
aggressive especially on issues like
this but by and large it had all it
worked even better because I could be
careful in what I was discriminating and
then to Ally that with calmness actually
made it more potent rather than less and
so that was very interesting and yeah
and I mean I mean we had a very serious
discussion about this my friends and I I
had a lot of people with me in Miami
when this was happening across the
political Spectrum we had a very healthy
debate for a couple of hours about
whether or not I had gone
Beyond some reasonable limit in the way
I was conducting myself Say on YouTube
and Twitter and some people were very
strongly advocating for more of what I
was doing and even harsher and others
were saying well you're alienating
people that you could otherwise
communicate with us it's interesting
about the listening like one of my sons
too my sons had come today because
that's one of the listen to this very
unusual well I've not even been to the
studio before so he just said to me
I said give me some advice you know you
love Jordan Peterson what's the advice
for the interview you said just listen
more than you normally do so I've tried
I've tried hard to ask a question and
let you answer right and so I'm work in
progress and I've been interviewing
people for 35 years but I do think the
listening as I've got older I felt the
same thing yeah it's a real skill man
listening is a is a powerful tool
actually oh yeah well there isn't people
there is nothing that people like more
and need more than to be listened to you
know and that's partly why the left
clamors all the time you know it says
look there's all these people who aren't
being listened to it's like there are a
lot of people who aren't being listened
to they're absolutely right there's no
doubt about that and I've dealt with
people who were extraordinarily
marginalized so to speak in my clinical
practice and some of those people to
straighten out their minds they need
like 10 000 hours of listening because
no one and I mean this literally I've
had people in my clinical practice
no one ever listened to them their whole
life yeah and so when you they start
talking they're all over the place
they're disorganized they're hyper
emotional they're distrusting and and
they have to have all that conversation
that you would have needed to become
properly interested
obviously Malcolm gladwell's famous
criteria for how people become greater
whatever it is from Tiger Woods to The
Beatles whatever uh they all put their
ten thousand hours of practice in
but you also believe that some people
just are gifted and I don't believe that
some people aren't well you think it's a
fat but it's clearly true well what I
would challenge you on that is simply
this that I've always felt probably
everybody has something in them there
could be an amazing talent but you do
but you have to find it yes and most
people probably never find whatever
their great right natural Talent could
be true that would be my take on it
that's true I and I otherwise they're
not it's not that they're not gifted
it's just they never found what their
gift was
uh that's very true all people are not
gifted at everything
and that's the general claim and and or
we're not equipotential in some sense
it's like
friends list could sight read any piece
of music the first time he saw it okay
and uh Neumann John Van Neumann some
people think he was the smartest man who
ever lived he could multiply 10 digit
numbers in his head when he was eight
you couldn't do that no no I can't do
that yeah I'm definitely not
mathematically gifted and so that is
genius I mean that is a gifted genius
thing to be doing but there must be huge
numbers of people who have this gift and
they just sadly through circumstance or
lack of opportunity they never get that
moment where they discover that's what
they're great definitely well that was
one of the lovely things about being a
clinical psychologist is that what you
were always doing what I was always
doing
in my clinical practice
was digging for gold you know and there
was often a lot of chaff like a lot what
would you what would you having met me
now for an hour what would your initial
clinical diagnosis be well you're
probably optimally disagreeable for your
for your profession
you know because you can listen but
you're also not a pushover and that's a
very that's a very fine line right
because if you're too assertive or
aggressive then you get domineering but
if you're not enough then you're a
pushover and to be and this was also the
case with Kathy Newman she's quite
disagreeable and that's that's a
masculine trait by the way and it was
one of the things I think mentioned into
it in a way is how we started the
interview she'd gone into I think with a
preconceived idea of what you would be
like and sort of stuck to that yeah it's
actually a very skillful journalist and
interviewer and I was surprised the way
that interview went when I was watching
it I think it was because she just had
an idea of what she thought you would be
well I think she probably I think she
also had an outcome an idea of what the
optimal outcome of the interview might
be and I think a lot of the journalists
who've
gone after me in some sense have that
they think they there's part of them and
thinks all be the person that finally
exposes him for what he is but then they
find out that I'm not who they thought
they that I at least I'm not quite as
demonic as they thought I might be well
talking somebody probably is as demonic
as we think he is uh Vladimir Putin and
Ukraine as we're doing this interview
he's been issuing more better Coast
threats about using nuclear weapons yeah
from so you're a surprise do you think
he would actually do that yes what kind
of person is he puta do you think
well he's a lot more like everybody else
than anyone thinks you know the notion
that he's Hitler or Stella and that's
just foolish I don't see any evidence
for that at all I mean first of all
Hitler and stellen were very singular
types and there's a bit of Hitler and
Stalin and everyone so you know there's
some truth and that maybe there's more
in the typical Russian language really
there's more than a bit really
oh absolutely yeah well why would have
not seism spread the way it did you know
people think well that's all top down
it's not top down there's there's a part
of people that are all these people who
informed on Kate Burleson well didn't go
but didn't gobble say that the way to
get vast numbers of people to go along
with what you want to do is to terrify
them yeah well that you can hold a grip
of Terror over them oh yeah but in a way
that's what puget's not doing with the
Russian people he's going back now into
a position of they're all trying to get
as they want to attack us they want to
take us over he's terrifying his people
to Rally support for what at the moment
is a conflict he has started which is
not going the way he assumed well the
most
um what would you say the wisest
commentators on totalitarian States like
like social Nets
and and many psychological commentators
young was a good example of that made a
very straightforward case that you can't
have a totalitarian state unless every
single person is willing to lie about
everything all the time and you can
think about that as top down because the
leaders lie too and they also enforce
punishments if you don't lie but then
you can also think about it
the the totalitarian spirit is
replicated at every level of the society
and so in a truly totalitarian state
husbands lie to their wives and parents
lie to their children and the
totalitarian state is actually the grip
of the lie and so and and people will
certainly go along with that I mean I
mean we're seeing that emerge here with
Castle culture it's like lie yes or else
yes like yeah well and the Russian
people will be bombarded all the time
with State media propaganda and we'll be
buying into a lot of what Putin is
saying yeah
how does this war end do you think
we're going to find out this winter well
I I know what I would do in his shoes
I'd wait till the first cold snap and
shut off the tops right well because I
was going to do this got the control
over there
of course he's going to do this he's
already warned the West with his
insistence that maintenance problems
were necessary and the pipelines do you
think he will use a nuclear weapon if
necessary he'll use a tactical
Battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't probably why
because we wouldn't respond
what's in it for us
if you let him do it and get away with
it where does that end then you are into
it well look there's a lot you can get
yourself in this situation no problem
where there's no good outcome we're
trying to do that right now on every
front we can possibly imagine we can
easily get ourselves in a situation
where it's hell this way and hell that
way that where that's highly probable
with should the ukrainians give the
Russians anything when I was over there
recently interviewing president
zielinski what I was struck by was
everybody I met in Keys the capital city
were utterly Resolute don't give them an
inch of our land yeah well I don't I
can't speak to that because I don't know
what the preconditions for peace might
be but I do know that naive Notions that
the Russians are going to lose somehow
or that we're going to win
I I don't I just don't understand I
don't understand that well what do you
mean we're going to win what are we
going to win here exactly well I guess a
victory would be that the Russians
retreated from Ukraine
with with Ukrainian ruins
right wow that's a hell of a victory
like I think Putin could manage that
because I think he could tell his people
and I think they might buy it it's like
we accomplished our objective we
devastated Ukraine and we kept it out of
the hands of the West and that's not
great
it's not what we'd hoped for but it's
better than the alternative and I think
they would buy that and I think when
Putin went into Ukraine I thought well I
thought a bunch of things which I I made
a YouTube video about that people
criticized like Matt I thought okay well
what's happening here oh I see
his his end game for failure is that
that Ukraine is left in a smoking room
oh that's a victory
so then he can lose with impunity right
so how can we win
we can't win against Vladimir Putin
anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to
period
and we can't say no to Putin because we
sold our soul for his oil and gas and we
did that to elevate our moral stature in
relationship to saving the planet and so
here we are yeah facing a very dire
winter
hoisted on the patard of our own
foolishness and moral presumption we're
saving the planet
we'll see I don't think so it doesn't
look like it to me and this is this is
the most catastrophic issue here
assuming that we're facing an
environmental crisis of planetary
proportions which is not something I buy
by the way assuming we are well then I
would imagine that you would put in
place measures that would ameliorate
that problem
instead of exacerbating it but all the
measures you're putting in place are
actually making the environmental
problem worse so how is that even
vaguely acceptable and I look at that
and I think oh I see it's just like
George Orwell said about middle class
socialists 50 years ago it's not that
you love the planet it's that you hate
Humanity
so well have at her boys and girls and
we'll see what happens this winter and
it's very terrifying to me I especially
here you know because your energy prices
have gone way out of control and that's
going to hurt a lot of poor people and
and certainly around the world as well
the World Bank already estimated that
we've put 350 million people into what
they call a food insecurity 350 million
that's three times as many as the
Communists managed to kill maybe we can
manage that in a winter but the planet
has too many people on it anyway so you
know that's just poor people you agree
with Elon Musk that we should have more
people not less
I see humans as a net good I know from
Marion tupi a man who just wrote a book
called Super abundance he's done the
economic calculations and he calculated
that every single baby born now will
produce seven times as many resources as
they will consume and you think well how
can that be it's like well it's not a
zero-sum game folks and maybe there's
enough to go around well there is maybe
there's more than enough to go around
because we can become hyper efficient
and you think well what's the evidence
for that it's like well there's twice as
many people as there were when I was a
kid and everyone's way richer so how
about that for evidence
so Professor Stephen Hawking before he
died gave me his last television
interview and he said that the biggest
threat to the future of mankind was when
artificial intelligence learned to
self-design what do you think the
biggest threat to mankind is
narcissistic compassion
now AIS you know it's a threat too but
if we if we're if we had our act
together ethically
it's possible that AI could become a
useful servant rather than a tyrannical
master
you don't want to automate your
tyrannical Masters and that's the danger
that's one of the dangers of AI I've got
to wrap it up I don't want to but I have
to I want to ask you just quickly uh the
film director Olivia Wilde has a new
movie out which she says it's based on
you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men uh who are despicable in many
ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized we're
supposed to have a voice
it's making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are and certainly
many young men are in that category and
you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what
does it mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it that's all oh by
that time you know that as far as as
critic critiques go that was kind of low
level I mean once I got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
there's no place past that so when
Olivia Wilde made those comments the
first thing I did was go look at the
preview for a movie which I quite liked
I thought I would go see that movie
probably and perhaps I will it didn't
really bother me my my family and I
talked about it right away and we were
able to respond to it with some degree
of humor which then people completely
misunderstood I said I hope that you
know that if I had to be played by
someone I think Chris Wilde is that
he's a very good looking man and so that
seems all right you know and then I said
something like I hope he gets my my uh
fashion style choice right when he plays
me and it was a joke all that was a joke
you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
it's really something to see
constantly
how many people
are dying for a lack of an encouraging
word
[Music]
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
and to say
you're in net force for good if you want
to be
do you believe you're not falsely good
net yes
in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much
Eve thank you you've got this new box
set up yeah yeah I'm pretty happy about
that 24 rules for life uh and Beyond
order uh fascinating books they've sold
how many millions now well 12 rules sold
seven and I think Beyond order is
approaching a million now so yeah
they're doing just fine you ever think
you'd sell that number of books I never
thought any of this would happen you
know I mean
so yeah I knew when I was teaching at
Harvard and at the University of Toronto
that some of the things I were I was
teaching were revolutionary I was
surprised that I got along with it got
away with it let's say as long as I did
and so there's a way in which it doesn't
surprise me and and I wouldn't say
that's because of the Brilliance of my
ideas it's because I'm I'm good at
communicating ideas but the ideas that
I've been developing their ancient ideas
they're the oldest ideas we have in some
real sense so you know they have a power
right absolutely your uh launch the
Peterson Academy tell me about that
quickly yeah well um I've been
collecting along with my daughter
um great professors and Educators from
all around the world and we're having
them come to Miami to film four two-hour
lectures on a variety of topics um
president of Hillsdale College Larry Arn
just taped one for us on Churchill which
I thought was quite funny because you
know he's persona non grata and so Aaron
and Churchill so that's quite funny and
we're hoping that we can determine how
to provide people a very efficient and
very low cost alternative to a
bachelor's degree and we're working hard
to make that accredited I'd like to
drive the cost of a bachelor's degree
from its current 160 thousand dollar
level to four thousand dollars and I
think I think we can do it so that's the
plan we're going to launch in either
early 2023 depending on how quickly we
can get things aggregated and so and I'm
working with my son on an app called
essay
essay.app it we we took a document I
wrote for my students that helped them
learn how to write and edit so and
editing is very important if you're
right and people are never taught to
edit and it builds editing tools into
the software and we have for 4 500
subscribers and 50 000 users we launched
about two months ago I'd like to teach a
million people to write
so and just finally you're healthy you
look healthy
pretty good and much better your wife's
doing a lot better than she was
she's back better than she was before
even and my daughter is not ill either
so fancy that I mean that's an amazing
turnaround from where you went that's
for sure man it was pretty
brutal yeah
for a long time yeah you know my wife
almost died every day for seven months
so
I'm very glad for you thank you sir I
really am and it's been a really a
fascinating interview
appreciate your time come back it's a
pleasure to see you I feel like we've
got a million more things I could talk
to you about which I'm sure everyone
thinks that when they talk to you well
that's a good that's a good thing to
have happen during an interview thank
you you bet man
one extraordinary interview with an
extraordinary character uh whatever you
think of Jordan Peterson you can't
listen to that and not be enthralled
captivated maybe challenged maybe you
don't agree with him I'm not sure he
Minds if you disagree with him that's
the whole point
it's about stimulating ideas it's about
challenging what you believe evolving
as we both do as we've got older that's
it for me whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive good night